time for our draft the most important
development from week three and Peter
Chris and I usually do a trivia question
when it's just me and him
we're expanding the trivia question to
the three-man weave I'm gonna ask you
the question if you get it right you get
the first pick if you get it wrong Chris
gets the first pick here is the question
Taylor Gabriel had three first-half
touchdown catches last night that ties
the Bears record set by which
hall-of-famer
I'll say Johnny Morris oh it would be
Mike Ditka Wow 1963 Wow with three I
don't even think Morris is in the Hall
of Fame but now that's a good one oh man
I didn't know Ditka had three and 1/2
that's pretty impressive Wow God okay
all right let's pick two you for first
pick to me last picked of Florio I like
this a lot most important developments
from week three I mean I don't like to
be obvious here but I'm gonna be Captain
Obvious I mean come on the story of week
three just the developments was Daniel
Jones how could I not start with that I
mean he took over for a hall-of-famer
and Eli Manning a guy who would beat the
New England Patriots twice daniel Jones
the number six pick of the New York
Football Giants boo who the hell's that
guy he stinks his highlights I was one
of those guys saying that but damn he's
proven it's wrong and not only prove us
wrong but he was phenomenal in the game
the other day and his talent shined
through his athletic ability is
toughness in the pocket the aggressive
nature throwing the ball down the field
I just think that's a no-brainer for me
as far as most important developments on
week three
alright I'll go second I'm gonna take
Chris Sims favorite AFC quarterback
Gardner Minshew
solidifying his spot on the on the 2019
all-pro team and also getting ready to
be fitted for his gold jacket in Canton
and also at the same time he's gonna be
on the cover of Rolling Stone this week
Wow
Gardner Minshew is my guy and I'm lying
there men shoe is my guy is the biggest
development of week 3 yeah I mean that's
a good one because who expected the
Jaguars to beat the Titans on Thursday
night Chris and I both had tennessee
winning that game the jaguars had some
life on offense their defense continued
to be very very good good enough to help
them get their win and moved to 1 & 2
alright for me it's what we saw on
Sunday night specifically what we didn't
see we didn't see Freddy kitchens
behaving like a seasoned NFL head coach
Freddy kitchens over his skis a little
bit admitting it yesterday with the idea
that hey I'm still new at this whole
thing with calling plays in crunch time
and not calling a running play and
calling a draw play on 4th and 9 so the
the notion that the Browns expectations
should significantly be tempered we kind
of sense that coming into the season we
got a taste of it week 1 in that 30
point loss to the Tennessee Titans but I
think it was loud and clear that Freddy
kitchens is is a work in progress and
that is going to affect what the
Cleveland Browns do in 2019 and we
should not expect them to even make it
to the playoffs this year guys yeah I
mean it's not looking great I'm not
giving up hope yet they're learning how
to win as in players and coaches like
you said ok it wasn't their best
performance they got a tough schedule
coming up here soon and we'll see that
they can weather this storm and and you
know make themselves relevant as far as
a playoff conversation alright my most
important my second thing I'm gonna go
with your it this is the I honestly I
like this pick it's not like sexy here
I'm not as cool as you guys minding
little cool angles alright but how about
I'm just gonna go the San Francisco
49ers are three you know that's one of
the most important developments from
week 3 that I look at and it's not just
like okay yeah there are three you know
there's other teams that are three and
football out there but this is the 49ers
who have been in struggles Ville the
last two years the first two years of
the Shanahan Lynch regime and of course
had such great hopes last year to kind
of turn things around and Jimmy
Garoppolo gets hurt so now we go through
the preseason and oh gosh Jimmy
Garoppolo looks like a disaster and
there's interceptions in practice and
what the hell is gonna go on well all I
know is the 49ers are three and O and
they're winning games where they turn
the ball over five times in a game I
think that kind of speaks to what the
49ers are they're three and O their
quarterbacks not even playing really
good football yet but they said the
second best defense in football through
three weeks right now guys they have the
fourth best offense in football they won
two road games and I just look at that
as being a major development and I think
it's pretty fair to say the 49ers are
here to stay I just like what I see and
they're gonna be in this playoff
conversation throughout the year my
second biggest development of week three
is that Patrick mahomes is now solidly
after facing a top five defense and
shredding the Baltimore Ravens he is now
you know on a comfortable pace to be the
first quarterback in NFL history to
throw for 6,000 yards and I'm just
saying unless he gets hurt you know
knock on Formica he's gonna I think he's
gonna win his second straight MVP going
away right and you look at him and look
at the way he plays everything he does
he's comfortable doing throwing off his
back foot some of the throws he makes I
mean you know Chris I know your dad is a
science of quarterback throwing yeah and
some of the throws that mahomes makes
phil simms has to look at them and say
what in the world are you doing and then
55 yards later it lands right in the
breadbasket you know and there's no
doubt just yeah it's real marvel at this
guy I'm with the appeal I said I'm
Martin I said last year go ahead go
ahead
last year I said kind of half in jest
he's gonna win seven MVP awards that may
be too long it really may be too long he
is he
is the moment look I've covered the NFL
for 35 years I have never seen a player
at that position come in and right from
his first start dominate the league the
way he has I mean it's the only one as
close and I missed him by one year is
Dan Marino yeah but he is just
absolutely remarkable in everything he
does yeah he hasn't changed at all has
not changed I interviewed him when he
was coming out from Texas Tech same guy
that he was three years ago and I don't
think the money's gonna change him and
the money is gonna be coming his way
after this season all right next one for
me
Dalvin cook is a stud that is a
significant development coming out of
week three we already kind of knew it
first running back in Vikings history to
have hundred yard games for each of the
first three games of a season that's a
franchise that has had guys like Adrian
Peterson and Chuck form and so a
significant development and when you
watch Dalvin cook it is man among boys
yeah the explosion that he has every
time he touches the ball he gets
positive yardage you don't see him get
swallowed up periodically behind the
line of scrimmage he gets the ball and
he goes he's averaging six point nine
yards per carry this year and this is
the guy that needs to be the centerpiece
of the offense sorry Kirk or Curt or
whatever your name is it needs to be
Dalvin time early often in constantly in
Minnesota and if they do that with their
defense this is a team that can make
some noise in January yeah Mike your
Vikings are dangerous man they're
dangerous cuz they're just it they're
gonna get the passing game going more
and more but they're playing Zimmer ball
and I'm mad you took him that was gonna
be my pick right there because I think
it is worthy I mean Dalvin cook is he's
put himself in the best best running
back in football conversation he's a
game changer you know as we like to say
he doesn't have just one rocket up his
butt he's got two of them up there and
that's why he's flying around the field
alright for my third pick you know um
I'm just gonna use your language there
Jacoby perset is a stud okay that's
where I'm gonna go the Indianapolis
Colts without Andrew Luck or two in one
very close to being three and OH but
they had the Atlanta Falcons coming into
town this week and the Indianapolis
Colts got off to a great start in the
football game we're up 22 three at one
point and why because Jacoby perset was
surging
call and the first half of that football
game he was phenomenal and everything he
did and he's been really damn good
through for the first three weeks of the
year to where you know I'm not gonna sit
here and go the Colts are the cream of
the crop in the AFC we know who that is
the Patriots the Chiefs but I think the
Colts have positioned themselves would
you Kobe were set to be that next next
group of teams down maybe with Baltimore
Ravens I mean they're good in all phases
of the game at Jacobi / sets proven that
he can carry the team and deliver when
he needs to in clutch moments and I
think that was really my biggest
question about him going forward
headline of week three Vic Fangio Denver
Broncos have their third straight
sackless game hmm
Bradley Chubb von Miller :
zero sacks yeah now that is one of the
most amazing things to me I was in their
training camp and I thought Bradley
Chubb was gonna get 17 and Von Miller 15
and they were gonna be the no doubt best
combo platter pass-rush team of the year
and that to me it's like you remember
the old NFL Films thing where Vince
Lombardi goes out on the field and says
what the hell is going on here yeah and
that is what I would be saying if I were
a Denver Broncos fan right now to Vic
Fangio what's crazier Peter is that his
old backup Shaquille Barrett down in
Tampa Bay he's got seven sacks that's
what's hilarious - that's amazing
alright last pick of the draft and and I
hate to repeat something that I
mentioned yesterday when we did Sunday
statement but I think that this really
was a significant development in Week
three of the morning calls plummet the
offensive holding calls plummet what do
you think I was going to say what what I
they're gonna talk you know talking
about Tom Brady and Twitter on a Friday
Twitter rant this this was the end
result of the offensive holding calls
plummeted from five point seven per game
to two point nine per day it needed to
happen
it was sparked by hash tag Tommy on
Thursday night on Twitter they had the
conference call with the officials on
Saturday night to reel this in I don't
like the fact that the the seasons
integrity has been undermined by two
weeks called one way and now it's going
to be fifteen weeks called another way
but this is good because there were too
many flags flying there are still too
many flags flying too many holding fouls
were being called and and to cut in half
the rate of offensive holding penalties
per game was a huge accomplishment this
weekend and it will resonate for the
rest of the year all right we gotta go
the the draft is done I have one last
pick I declare victory and I say we go
to break then no one can dispute me
we'll be back with over pft librarians
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports